so last week just after we've done the
video on dirty cow
there was another post from a team of
engineers at NC Lowe and written up in a
very good blog post by tal Lieberman
explaining an exploit they'd found in
Windows called which they termed at
embalming now the lovely thing about
this exploit is it works in any version
of Windows and they reckon it's
virtually undetectable by your
anti-malware software of course what
this means then is that you don't
necessarily know that it's not already
being exploited on your system at the
simplest level at embalming is just a
way for us to take a piece of code that
we want to execute and not run it as
part of our program but co-opt some
other program to execute that code for
us so say I'm writing a nice piece of
software that's going to sit in the
background and log every single key
press you press on your Windows machine
know that I'll get all your passwords
I'll get all your bank details and I'm
going to disguise it as a nice printer
driver for that nice new printer that
you've bought now I do that you've got a
bit of an anti-malware software on there
and it says hey this printer drivers
trying to talk to the Internet and you
go that's a bit suspicious why is my
printer driver trying to talk to the
Internet and you stop it and you find
the thing and uninstalling what this was
allow us to do is to say we still write
our piece of code hiding in Si a printer
driver and we say well not going to get
connect directly so we get Firefox or
Chrome or ie to send the details back to
the hackers so they've got all your
details and of course if a message
popped up saying chrome wants to connect
to the internet
also you're going to let it connect and
so what we've got is a prettier piece of
software and we're writing our malicious
program here and it's executing so we
represent it with a skull and crossbones
and we wanted to run something so we
have Google Chrome over here so we've
got our program here and rather than
sending the information directly it pops
a piece of code into chrome and gets
chrome to execute the code for it and of
course it's connecting to the internet
and it happily sends it through because
that's what Chrome is designed to do
alternatively you could pop a piece of
code into Chrome or Firefox or any other
program that access to all the passwords
that are stored in Chrome and then send
them off happily over the Internet and
you would never know it was happening
now this is a standard carried injection
technique lots of malware to use things
like this what's clever about this and
where it gets its name from is the way
it's implemented in that it uses
built-in features of Windows that have
been there for donkey's years to
transfer the data from your program the
malicious one into a Chrome or whatever
it is you want to exploit and then
execute the code that's there and so
that's why it gets its name at embalming
because it makes use for featuring
Windows called atoms so what is an atom
well often when you're writing programs
things you need to represent things and
one way you can do that is by using a
string so if you want to pass a piece of
information from one part of a program
to another program you need to tell it
what type of information that is and one
way you could do that is just put a
string with it that says this is an
image or this is a piece of text or
whatever it is and that would work you
could put the image with it and the
other program could compare that text
with a list of known types and then it
can work out what it wants to do with it
the problem with that is that the text
is arbitrary long so it takes an
arbitrary amount of space to transfer
which sort of changes each time and also
it takes a significant amount of time to
compare the two strings you have to
compare each character until they don't
match and then go on to the next one and
compare it and so on so atoms are
created is a sort of way around this
what you basically do is you create an
assam from the string and that gives you
a sixteen bits or a number between 0 and
65536 that represents that string we
won't go to the details of how it's done
but the key thing is that every time you
create an atom for the same string or
the same sequence of characters you get
the same atom back so you then just pass
around the 16-bit numbers and you can
compare them and they act just as if
they were strings but they're faster and
smaller to use because you've got that
table behind them which maps them
between the at anumber and the string
that is being used what Windows offers
is built-in support for providing atoms
which is quite common in an operating
system and so you've got functions that
will allow you to create the
find them and get the text back from
them what it also provides which is what
at embalming exploits is a global Optima
table this is an atom table which is
shared by all programs that probably
could have their own local tables which
they can use as they need but there's
this global one which is shared between
all the programs and say if you want to
use something like for example dynamic
data exchange between two programs you
use the atoms in the global table
because then they can both see them so
what we've got we just redraw this is
our malicious program over here and
we've got chrome sitting here so what
our program can do our malicious program
is it can create a global atom and it
gets added to the atom table and chrome
if it were to look for that after it
could get the string as well so they can
both see it and this is the first part
of the thing this gives us a way to get
information ie the code we want to run
from a malicious program into the
program we want to exploit so if this is
the parasite we can get it into the host
so what we do is we create an atom and
there's a standard window system score
we can use to create the atom and we
give it the machine code for what we
want the program to do so we create a
bit of machine code and we create an
atom with that bit of code so then we've
got a piece of got an atom that's shared
between every program on the system
great how do we actually get that into
our program that we want to use well we
use another window system call which
enables us to run a function inside
another process in this case we're going
to exploit chrome to do it and so the
way that that works is we first call it
passing it the function we want to call
in this case the function which goes off
and gets the value of the atom from the
atom table so we're using this program
so let's say we've got the atom table
down here this uses global add atom to
put the malicious code into the atom
table we then need to do the next bit of
the exploit which is to get Chrome or
whatever program we're trying to attack
to call the function to get at the value
so we want this program to call
global get Adam name to transfer the
code that we've put in here which is
pretending to be the string into our
host process in this case we're using
Chrome but it's not an export in Chrome
any process would be susceptible to this
so we can transfer the information from
a malicious program through the atom
table hence why it gets the name atom
bombing because we're using the global
atom table as a sort of vector into the
other program but we need to get global
get atom name called from within chrome
now how do we do that
well we can use one of the standard
windows functions that enable us to run
an asynchronous procedure in another
process so this is a standard thing and
you might use this to do remote
procedure calls that sort of thing it's
not anything to under on toward now you
have to be a little tricky with this
because of the way that data is passed
into these functions but you can get it
to work so we can make our program here
call that in that one and that copies
the value into the memory space of the
host program that we want to exploit so
we can using standard windows systems
calls just copies data from here into
here now at this point we need to
execute the code inside the host process
now you might think well you can just
call the to queue the asynchronous
procedure call again but one of the
things that modern operating systems
doing whether it's Windows Mac or Linux
they use what's called the NX bit to say
that only certain memory locations can
execute code so any programs loaded into
memory you set this know execute bit the
NX bit so that only certain pages of
your program can be executed either ones
where you've loaded your code in so you
transfer your message or program across
but you can't execute it you find
somewhere to hide it that's easy to do
you copy it across but you can't execute
it so what you end up having to do is to
do some clever return-oriented
programming ie making use of code that's
already in the program and stringing it
together so it executes in the order
that you want it to rather than the
order that it was intended to do to
create a new bit of memory in the
program
which is marked as executable and then
copy the value that you've already
copied into there into this part and
then start executing it the result is
that you can use the atom table to
transfer your code across and then using
some clever master Nations which is
described in the blog post so we're go
to the details here execute your code
inside another program and then it can
do whatever you like so I've taken the
program that NC low release to
demonstrate this and I've got it
installed on Visual Studio so we've got
chrome running and if we just run the
program what this will do is you will
see the code float up here as it does
all the various stages it'll then get
chrome to execute the bit of code we saw
earlier and it will pop up with the
calculator so it's actually executing
the calculator it's not very destructor
it's not very much of an example but
we'll see that it actually does what it
says on the tin off it goes and then
boom the calculators popped up behind me
and it's run it and I never run the
calculator this program leather around
the calculator this program got chrome
to run it on its behalf and there's no
trace inside chrome or inside this
program that this ever happened and of
course the real problem with this is
that there's no easy way for any sort of
antivirus or anti-malware to detect that
this is what's going on it would have to
start patching into the window system
calls and checking whether global a data
was being passed with what looked like
actual text or machine code you'd have
to check what was being passed into
global a data was valid text which is
what you expect will actually look more
like machine code which would slow the
system down whatever that was used you
would have to check every asynchronous
procedure call to check it wasn't
calling global get out of name to pass
the text into the other thing so it'd be
really quite difficult to detect this
being happening I'm sure they'll find a
way but at the moment it's the wild west
out there look
surrounded by all this Apple merchandise
and some people might accuse computer
file of bias in our coverage what you
want to just set all fears at rest
we've looked at how we can exploit open
SSL we've looked at how we can exploit
bash in the past today we're going to
look at how we can exploit windows this
isn't by us that